Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
What job that does not exist today do you think will be one of the world's "top 10" jobs in 10 years?
Well, right now, the thing that scientists
and I think a lot of businesses also need
that's really hard to find
is somebody who is sophisticated about data
and knows how to manage
large quantities of information
and distill out something that's important
and actionable from all those details.
So, I think that's going to be a very important skill.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.